mais harry dans les souillés dans la
neige lioret de souliers de souliers
dans la neige qui était tombée
blanc
dimanche à grands pas à grands pas grâce
à n'en vois pas
le deuxième dans
et là c'est le levier
et c'est dans le troisième a même viré
sur le troisième
non rien aperçu
et demain sur les way pas besoin d'un
boulot
les capsules mince filet il y fait bien
d'autres
bref nous irons
en quarts c'est sur des autos sans nom
alors un des plus aisés des bassins et
des contraventions et de ses doigts
magiques m ainsi sous les lampions 1
jusqu'à angers lesquels je rêve
cadets 1
possible ouais
et bien voilà ouzou lady gaga qui sont
là ce soir et je suis très content très
heureux je me suis venu venger le viano
d'ailleurs hoya va bien maison vous
présenter ma grande amie anne long de
l'erdre liminaire veilleuse il vérifie
j'ai bien choisi ses musiques de fiat a
choisi leurs yeux d'ailleurs les parmi
nous ce soir vous propose 2 de l'appuyer
de l'avenir très fort
en cela bien je suis venu pour vous
parler d'un sujet qui j'espère va tous
vous intéressé puisqu'il s'agit des
vacances des congés du tourisme en
général bref d'une situation
véritablement traumatisant par les temps
qui courent tenez prenez l'exemple de
paulette merval est marcel merkès eh
bien ils sont allés passer une partie de
leurs vacances
woodstock chez les hippies histoire de
prendre un bain de foule dans une foule
qui ne prend plus jamais de bain depuis
longtemps à votre droite paulette merval
et à votre gauche marcel merkès
croyez moi c'est parlement
non
non tirées
oui
et
l'écouté merci vous l'êtes merval et
merci marcel merkès oui oui c'est
merveilleux c'est bien de chez nous et
bien écoutez maintenant toutes les
petites filles et tous les petits
garçons toujours parmi nous ce soir à
provins de la patrie d'un père fuite
vers orange un couple de plusieurs
présenter ma charmante amy d'un lead
dalida qui elle est allée passer ces
petites vacances sur la côte d'azur vous
semble-t-il d'ailleurs la foule des
petits des petits baigneurs et des
petites baigneuses bien de chez nous ne
l'avons absolument pas gêné puisqu'il
paraît ma chère dalida que lorsque vous
aviez sur le sable vous vous mettiez à
chanter et instantanément
vous aviez toute la plage pour vous tout
seul c'est merveilleux c'est magnifique
en l'écoutant mécontents l'écouté
maintenant nous faire un très grand
plaisir en ne chantant à tous mes amis
et un tout petit ami un très grand
succès qu'a eu énormément de succès nous
écoutons
il est triste et les jours de départ y
dîner calandre et les toits mais c'est
que les communes en bois et
tous les sons et les sauces en fait née
ont pété voir
ah ben ça j'aime apple connu je suis
dans la rue je suis seul je suis seul
si si
gc non
ressemble moins à l'accord par les
cowboys au sous sol
à chaud sous deux formes en sommes
d'ailleurs oui tu savais british but je
m'étais entend pas je ne vous entends
pas non plus d'ailleurs
alors demandé le fichier
elle est ma voix mais avec mes doigts
comme ceci seulement faites bien
attention
chelsea se préparer y at il quelqu'un
qui va laisser ce soin à ses débuts
s'entend pas j'ai beau très beau château
de recul avec rage au sous sol les
copains les copines yacha jamais su ce
soir je suis donc plus c'est seule auto
à quand le baigneur c'est dingue
aso lui sur le hac est revenue à fait
contre le fola blanche
us soit ensuite on répare les attentes
porto rozes a que 100 faut sept ans
plein
l exemple à chapeau
est ce vrai jean coutrot
et
celle ci soit choisi l'usam à canton en
feu
est ce de descente et on a deux camps
seront dans le faire sur un bateau en
bon bout hayat anvers
une plante
m
à 40 ans
genève quand je te fous j
on comprend pourquoi n'y en a pas deux
fois ya celle que j'avais su ce soir que
genève
ouais
alors les petits voyous voulaient qu'on
l'a vu à la télé renault fils car
mitterrand le pape oui mais ils ont des
tubes
bah ouais giscard ça commence toujours
par bonsoir madame bonsoir mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur je suis venu comme à
chaque rendez vous télévisé ou rassurez
vous rassurer sur le franc qui est fort
qui est stable qui est tenace le franc
qui ne cesse de grimper
je parlais du franc suisse est
évidemment je le ferais foucades et elle
nous l'a laissé c'est un peu différent
je voudrais vous parle également de
l'armée il ya de plus en plus de femmes
dans l'armée
quelle femme les femmes gp temps je les
passe en revue de temps j'entends et au
moins me rassure je me dis avec elle
la france est un viol à paris volé son
vélo l'un dans l'autre économiquement
parlant
la france arrive maintenant on peut le
dire nettement avant le groenland et
mitterrand le dernier 33 toit était
limitée roma c'est vrai ouais je dirais
françaises français je remercie l avance
les électeurs qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux c'est vrai que de plus en plus
de françaises et de français en france
grâce à michel debré qui avait dit à un
moment l'assemblée nationale il faut que
les françaises et les français les
phases des enfants sur une grande
échelle
patatras et feuilla il ya en france un
avion étonnant de le concorde
c'est le seul avion qu'on nous a pas
pris d'assaut les autres avions les
détourner le nôtre nous le retournement
jeu sur sa très étonnant il ya autre
chose que j'ai pas bien compris c'est le
départ subit de jacques chirac manquer
je n'aimais pas jacques chirac pour que
jeunes iront pas puisque brive où mes
médias ferment ce troisième dimanche
après la pentecôte je pense que les
seigneurs qu'est ce que je raconte mais
non excusez-moi je suis complètement
mutilés par la main tendue aux
catholiques par monseigneur marché d'un
j'ai peur qu'il ait commis là un pc
mortel est alors le peuple
dia pape a parlé de monseigneur lefebvre
ici et à l'audiovisuel écran oui la vie
m'a dit ça va mieux avec le pape
ah oui ce sera la messe en latin bah oui
quand on sait comment ça s'est passé
c'est chouette le pointu aux coups durs
cela il me reste pas de nemo pour
acheter ton be quant à tort parce
qu'avec monde est toujours on peut très
bien
vous excuser d'interrompre internet
quelques instants afin de laisser la
place à monsieur le président de la
république pour un entretien au coin du
feu
décidé à la dernière minute bonsoir
messieurs dames cher public spectateur
tout ça machin est copains ça va bon là
on est là au coin du feu
ces rapports un entretien au coin du feu
pour avec monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing qui est président de dell qui
est président il se comporte très bien
doté de quoi il est président c'est
marqué sur la présidente de la
république française
normalement c'est jacques essentielle
qui devait assurer l'entretien mais il
est un peu il est un peu patraque c'est
à dire qu'il a il avalé un échiquier
il a passé une radio mais moi je vais
très bien faire la faire pour
l'entretien avec le président je pense
que le président devrait plus tarder
maintenant
m
bonsoir momo président bonjour madame
bonsoir mademoiselle bonsoir monsieur je
suis venu pour répondre aux questions
que vous êtes en droit de vous poser
concernant l'actualité gouvernement cac
pour vous chauffer les mimines si vous
remercie et j'aimerais d'ailleurs élu d
un certain nombre de malentendus dont un
qui consiste à prétendre que le
président connaît les questions à
l'avancé faux et ne connaît que les
réponses soient je vous ai monsieur le
président nous allons évidemment parler
des municipales à nu ce que non non sa
nounou j'ai demandiez cas de mariée
vision n'en parlent pas l'objet de gens
qui vous abstenez vous parler d'autre
chose il ya deux ans plus cruciale la
culture c'est quand même demain ses
marques et c'est pas demain rue il ya
plus précieux alors de là on peut
peut-être parler du chômage s'est ain
est préoccupant c'est bien je suis
heureux que vous me parliez du soma ah
ben on savait que nous connaissons une
période de sorite de chômage en france
puisqu'il ya environ plus de chômeurs
cette année que l'année dernière mais
nettement moins que l'année prochaine
si tu fais que grosso modo
économiquement parlant la france arrive
nettement avant le brain lente
abbas et principale face du mans contre
le projet de l'anru ils ont dix ans
d'une bonne coins de l'inde ils ont bon
ben monsieur le vice jusqu'à machin
appelé ma valérie l'enchère valley tout
ça je pense qu'on pourrait maintenant
aborder le problème des municipales qui
est quand même assez n'ont eu qu'un
jeune âge j'ai demandé qu'on ne parle
pas des municipales à la télévision même
pas
le demain parce que celle de max écoutez
il ya d'autres peut-être parler du franc
le franc on veut pas dire que ce soit le
forez pour vous savez le franc est fort
quoi qu'on dit le franc est stable
francs et tenace on peut parler du franc
suisse est vide à blanc ouais bah c'est
pas loin ce sont ce constat côté y en a
qui connaissent le chemin
abbas et on peut pas parler de ça parce
que
bon et maintenant mon cher valley tous
étaient au lit je vais t'appeler
l'insoumise un peu ça fait du ballet
valérie ci est un problème de nous re
actuellement c'est celui des municipales
qui comme norme wi mais on ne peut pas
en parler
près du tout mais alors si si un
problème pas de le re voilà on nous dit
de partout monsieur valéry qu
actuellement l'armée connaîtrait des
problèmes militaires notamment ceux
singulièrement il s'agirait il vaut
mieux qu'elles ne connaissent que des
problèmes d'ordre militaire
oui c'est fondamental oui et je vous
dirais que j'ai tout fait pour rehausser
le prestige de l'armée puisque lorsqu'il
ya eu la grève des éboueurs et
qui est-ce qui a ramassé les poubelles
si vous monsieur le président nos petits
cons c'est l'armée ces normes et voyez
la particule ans que je lutte et moi oui
monsieur le président d'ailleurs vous
savez que la france est prête à résister
à toute agression
à condition que ça ne tombe pas le jour
de la grève des éboueurs
nous allons de plus en plus de femmes
dans l'armée nous avons madame des
proches de tellement bonne entente entre
les cuves de ma femme parce que ça ne
voudra pas si elle était là parce que
mais oui les femmes d'affairé si vous
marquez contre les vers se sont éteints
direct ce sont des femmes est patente
je les passe en revue de temps en temps
réel leur âge je me dis avec elle la
france est inviolable
ah bon alors on glisse si on parlait des
minimes si l'on écouté et nous allons
répondre tout j'ai demandé que l'on ne
parle pas des municipales à la
télévision dont alors on pourra
peut-être aborder le plus haut mais mon
cher valérie que vous allez voir comme
c'est pas de la tarte
le rapport à l'université l'université
connaît d'elle aussi des mets coutume en
ce qui concerne l'univers séité je dois
vous dire que la rentrée scolaire s'est
fort bien passé puisque je n'en dis
qu'il y ait de plus en plus de crs de
façon à effectuer dans les meilleures
conditions possibles le ramassage
scolaire
alors voilà comment ça s'est passé après
un examen de passage à 4 bat les élèves
vont te tiens ramener chez eux la
plupart du temps dans je ne cachais
petit cheveu gens pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique française
weeks essentiel et fondamental
fondamental dans cette fin de saison est
d'avoir mais j'aurais aimé vous me
critiquer cette femme vous mais vous me
donniez votre sentiment à propos d'une
phrase que monsieur mitterrand a dit
l'autre jour dans son langage admirable
london enfin dans son langage
annales dans dans son jargon dégueulasse
il a dit il parlait il a dit enfin
c'était pas très hâte à 100 je pourrai
mais choisissez en syrie nous avons pris
et là monsieur mitterrand a donc dit et
en parlant de marché monsieur marchait
marché et moi nous sommes comme cul et
chemise est ce que vous pouvez délayé et
m'expliquer cette phrase une chronique d
avant d'aller au fond des choses
non on ne peut pas tout de suite parce
que moi je vous ai bouffé la vente
il faudrait savoir lequel des deux faits
la liquette oui en plus tout mais toute
façon vous en foutez vous vous situez au
dessus des partis
vous l'avez déjà dit vous avez une âme
aura alors sans que c'est pas tellement
mon président pour peut-être s'en aller
donc on ne parle pas d'eux des peut pas
parler d'eux c'est bien simple on aligne
le droit de parler d'eux
ni des élections municipales qui ont
lieu demain deux mamies tous aux urnes
c'est sodium peut pas parler français
mais de la mademoiselle monsieur quand
on n'a plus rien à dire on se retire
bonsoir
ga
le problème avec lui c'est que philippe
bouvard était un petit peu plus petit
que moi je vais être obligé de retirer
mes chaussures
bonsoir bien suis très heureux d'être
parmi vous je remercie daniel gilbert de
m'avoir invité dans cette émission
et s'il vous le voulez bien et bien
jouer tout de suite demandé à l'une de
mes plus fidèles pensionnaires alice
sapritch de venir nous rejoindre par le
duplex que je vais tenter d'organiser
maintenant avec elle et jacques pierre
alors jacques pierre ont pris nous
envoyer alice sapritch s'il vous plaît
je pense que nous n'allons pas tarder à
l'avoir bonsoir alice ça va bien alice
vous m'entendez ce cas vous m'entendez
soit fini je vous entends très bien
bonsoir ali dit moi c'est charmant votre
petit intérieur là et ce n'est pas mal
c'est un modeste appartement d'une femme
honnête oui puis votre robe est assez
sexy aussi c'est chouette avoue trouver
- c'est une robe que mon ami paco
rabanne fabrique près de 3 l et gandhi
dont je suis pas venu pour parler de
votre garde-robe vous en doutez bien
alice non je suis venu quand vous
demander de nous parler de la sexualité
dont vous êtes un spécialiste l'ont été
sur philippe que vous alliez me poser
cette question se produiront non pas que
la sexualité soit saugrenue non non mais
de la façon où vous m'amenez je sais ce
que vous allez me poser comme question
mais la sexualité j'avoue que je
commence à en avoir un peu marre
pourquoi parce que on ne parle que de ça
c'est à croire que les gens ne banquent
plus haut et ça ça me gêne beaucoup
vraiment je fais un cours à cournon une
rencontre avec de jeunes élèves j'aimais
beaucoup les gens écoles hec et ont été
tuées au chili hôtes ses pubs cochonnes
vous venez de dire oui et bien je fais
une rencontre assez agréable dans
l'instant un visage et un très charmant
ces jeunes élèves qui se destine à des
études l'austère seulement à l'arrière
austère et entre autres on m'a posé
aussi des questions saugrenues dans le
style
écoutez su bloquer bloqué ce terme
bloqué ridicule d'ailleurs je suis
bloqué est ce que vous croyez que
l'amour à plusieurs c'est plus naturel
je leur ai répondu écoutez mes petits
chéris mais petit chéri jusqu'à présent
les fabricants dany ont fait des lits
pour une personne pour deux personnes
pour manou soyez devant tu utiliser
l'e10 pour pour votre partenaire c'est à
dire pour deux personnes et ne soyez pas
14 points de moins à la ce que je leur
ai répondu tu me lis après le succès
énorme
vous accepteriez de grimper au septième
ciel avec moi ah non je m'arrêterai au
premier est ce qu'il vous arrive d'être
agressés dans le métro quelques fois
alice sapritch compote de m le métro
figure pour la bonne raison que je suis
très occupé je prends ou soit la voiture
d'une production ou alors l'autobus que
pouvez-vous faire agresser dans
l'autobus
non on ne m'agresse pas comme ça non il
ya d'autres personnes mieux qualifiés
que moi je vous le fais pas dire à l'iss
vous avez des projets actuellement chat
ça ne vous intéresse pas par exemple le
fait que je fasse mon métier avec un
metteur en scène je viens de tourner
avec guy lux et un bon métier rarement
avec sim comme partenaire je viens de
tourner avec michel galabru le film de
marc beurre mais c'est je sais que ça ne
nous intéresse pas ce qui vous intéresse
c'est big three et bien soyons soyons
dans votre tonalité faisant des gugusses
ri ensemble si vous voulez bien
dites-moi alice sapritch pour terminer
si vous aviez un conseil à donner aux
jeunes qu'est ce que ce serait diplo se
seraient ceux ci baiser et n'en parlait
plus aux plaisirs madame
eh bien monsieur manche et je suis
heureux que finalement les carpentier
est organisée c'est encore un monopole
toujours la défense des monopoles magin
gizc antennes et rob kazinsky manche et
lui feront julie france soupire chevreau
gens m'écoutaient je m'excuse monsieur
le chef du gouvernement provisoire mais
c'est très simple c'est parce qu'un
arbre messier bas ça fait des mois que
je cours après ce débat on invite le
leader de l'opposition passait pas
mitterrand témoin à la télévision tous
les années bissextiles et quand j'arrive
on me dit de me taire alors quand est-ce
qu'ils causent leurs représentants des
travailleurs et des lois ce populaire
jeu moche je vous en mets jour toujours
beau vous serrez la main mais il n'en
est pas question
oui jouer ce que vous me laissez pas
terminée j'aimerais vous serrez l'homme
quand phil est le monde vous poser comme
étant notre meilleur allié monsieur
marché oui je le dis vous êtes le leader
de la désunion de la gauche c'est
peut-être pas la peine de crier sur les
toits s'arrangeait faire la cuisine
électorale en dehors la télé venir
écouter monsieur manche j'ai eu si une
toute une série d'articles journée 15 kg
qui m'attendent encore et je m'aperçois
que françois mitterrand et vous d'après
vous déclaration commune vous n'êtes
quand et abel les premiers frères gille
arrêtez monsieur bah je vais vous dire
quand j'ai vu monsieur giscard d'estaing
vous présenter aux travailleurs et aux
smicards exploités sur les marches de
l'elysée
on savait qu'ils s'étaient lors elle et
qui s'est terminée sur un attaquant
laissé tomber les gants paraissent nous
j'en veux raison monsieur manche elles
ne seraient peut-être au pendant votre
entre eux mais vous n'allez tout de même
pas critiquer mon physique
oh non je m'en garderais bio parce que
moi je suis comme je suis monsieur le
premier ministre je ne devrais pas les
travailleurs j'irai jamais en
consultation chez un chirurgien
et vous avez raison monsieur monsieur ça
vous évitera une grosse dépense polluer
moins
équeutez les travailleurs impressionnant
et enfin je marchais d'abord il ya une
chose que très énervante filant le
mouron c'est que vous pensez sans arrêt
les travailleu mai mais cécile de parler
des travailleurs mais écouter mais moi
j'ai à la lettre mais messier mais à
l'oreille c'est un scan à remercier le
club mais c'est ainsi a strada
la france y atteler from my hair vous
êtes le chef du gouvernement voulait pas
qu'on parle de travail et amédée qui
sait qu'on va creuser alors tu sais qui
sont les travailleurs les travailleurs
mais si elle va donner dans des notes là
ils sont dans le noir de laàs des prix
et des chômages métier bas le choc je
vous parlais du noir je pourrais vous
paru du rouge
ce serait comme dostoïevski que vous
connaissez j'espère oui mais tu es c'est
pas parce que vous avez lu les auteurs
polonais qu'il faut nous donner des
leçons de culturelle par 15 écarts
restent en france dimanche il s'agit là
quand même d'entraîneur du bambin bon et
ben larbi dedans qui vous êtes pire vous
n'essayez pas le menu a reconnu nous ne
ferons
oui ça c'est la belle giscard d'estaing
mais qui dort à voter pour vous aux
élections monsieur marché la majorité
des français je vous le dis aux passants
oui alors évidemment c'est possible mais
si vous choisissez le triangle gfl
enquête le payante qui vous réussit si
bien dans les circonscriptions dauphine
la muette passy fraîche votre réunion il
ya quatre côtés et monsieur man show
mais vous savez en lésine pas sur les
moyens dans l'union de la gauche en f1 à
une virgule près puis alors monsieur
marché - il ya une chose que je remarque
c'est à marie deux autres je vous
parlais de socialisme à visage humain ou
et 6 à boussac
écoutez il suffit de vous regarder pour
s'apercevoir que c'est pas pour demain
mais ça c'est encore un autre scandale
un plus bas à moi j'avais demandé un
débat pleine démocratie et on se
retrouve sur un ring de boxe avec
monsieur marché c'est vous qui avez
comme on vient c'est vous monsieur ben
monsieur
les chanter moi c'est même cheyrou mais
silver dessus le marché un côté je dois
écouter alors là je m'excuse peut pas
laisser passer ça excusez-moi s'exercer
profondément été cordiale
est ce que moi j'ai parlé des aventures
du petit éléphant qui amuse tant les
petits enfants moi j'ai pas attaquer
votre patronyme monsieur baba que non
seulement je vous dit non c'est non je
ne dis pas n'importe quoi
vous êtes le passé et moi je suis
l'actuel sevré d'un mur je vous trouve
très punk ont coûté joyeux convenant
bien des travailleurs qui regardent la
salle
ce n'est pas mon souci c'est très à la
mode nous et rain monsieur manche le
prêtre était alors vous êtes vous parlez
trop con étrangers je ne peux pas suivre
par conséquent au lieu de faire des
anglais cyclisme vous feriez mieux de
prendre votre carte du parti aux unions
l'époque question mais vous avez tort
parce que c'est encore le meilleur moyen
la voix un hlm
vous savez quand je reviens de moscou
monsieur man show oui j'ai vu ça dans
l'humanité oui ben j'ai une grosse épine
ça vous fait de la part des quilles de
huit bonsoir
irrité qu'est ce que tu peux l'aider
après sunday dalida et la wii elle fait
un raccord à bord de deux petites
minutes
il paraît que le type avec qui elle
était gigi l'amoroso à oui oui ça me va
elle avec un nouveau maintenant certains
chichi valentino un peu louche un papa
joe dassin quand même sympa jusque là
jean chirac plutôt comment la dali
d'arabe
il a les cheveux plaqués des lunettes
sur le nez
j'étais en face aux ardennais sont
complets biais nous et elles posent à la
télé foot avec lui elle est passée à lui
allé vendre nos rayons madhavan des
fraudes la tomate
chez le vent mais les blues en ag nous
sommes dans la vérité mais parce qu'ils
mentent allons poser et qu'en prime
imposée
je suis mal en pis
j'entends me
mais jamais attaqué paris va rester
oh
j'arrive mais tout le monde même les
électrices se sont plaints que de l'uci
pendant belge et la femme du boulanger
machin avec le monde pour une histoire
de croissants en libye la femme du
notaire qui vaut deux bruxellois reibel
qui ne l'avait jamais trop mais
auparavant
même à la fiancée de monsieur moto il
faut nous y c'est vous dire le tout de
même nom et surtout moins bien sûr
qu'ils aimaient bien mitterrand depuis
longtemps
titi c'est toi j -g laisse moi te le
garder dans le noir qu'est ce qu'il y en
a qui ne vont pas çi et des cartels il
n'a pas voulu te vois alors mes classes
qui composent cette amérique et en
parlant que tu puisses et les cacahuètes
tu voulais en année comme ça en amérique
peut-être fallait-il américaine au liban
mais qui peut pas temps d'aller comme ça
tu chies nbc pour nous tuer jade raymond
vall eric chirac et ukrainiens ici que
là-bas tu les entends c'est un militant
m
lee
et
donc la queue bonsoir mâcha rallye
bonsoir sur une série mans michal ouled
rigueur oui n'est moins sûr la série
alice la crue et cas pas été tendre pour
super dupont mais apparemment où vous
paraissait détendu
oui je suis détendu - chérie chéri
moralement parce que physiquement je
suis plutôt attendu disons moins dans ma
carrière j'ai eu plus de lifting que de
rappel mieux réussir et bien regarde par
exemple là quand je serre les fesses et
les paupières qui se ferme
c'est extraordinaire non moins avec ce
qu'il mentirait je me suis fait un sac à
main d'ailleurs ma chère à l'iss oui mon
michel où naît lorsque vous êtes venu
dans son viseur ya pas très longtemps on
m'avait dit que vous étiez très branché
avec les jeunes que tout allait bien et
que certains jeunes vous trouver non
seulement beaucoup de charme et un
certain sex-appeal oui j'ai du succès
avec les antiquaires et brocanteurs mais
aussi avec les les jeunes oui j'ai du
sex apeal asec sa fille louis fans ne
citons pas de marque à la télévision mon
truc alice la télé le théâtre doit
beaucoup vous n'êtes pas de monstre
sacré sarko plaisir oui je suis un
monstre ça tu fais bien de le dire -
chérie chéri mais c'est vrai les
directeurs des deux théâtres mais
doivent beaucoup car avec moi ils font
des économies de chauffage d'électricité
puisqu'ils ferment à l'entracte
généralement sauf quand je sers les les
grands auteurs que mais comment
s'appelle-t-il cet angle l acquis qui
meurt tout le temps je clapote de jeu
william shakespeare ou non chez williams
j'exprime oui avec j'expire j'ai pas pu
éviter le four mais avec jacques sogepa
éviter le filleul
nasir ali
ma chérie comme tous les musées qui me
plaît ce week-end et je te trouve aussi
viril que lino ventura mon jeu j'ai vu
dans les coulisses machir alice comme
toutes les grandes tragédiennes vous
respectez le sexe oui oui on peut dire
mon chéri que abba gardner listello
chéries-chéris composent
moi je me décompose j'ai tout fait dans
ma carrière chazot le cg j'ai fait du
doublage de dessins animés maintenant
j'ai des saints à réanimer plutôt fun
les enfants sont fous de moi en france
souvent ils me jettent des pierres dans
la rue quand je passais aux états unis
écrit après moi ici ma chère à l'iss oui
pour réussir oui mon briquet dans une
vie de comédienne il faut une silhouette
un certain galp en plus de son talent
d'acteur mais malheureusement je n'ai
pas le physique de claudia cardinale
mais j'ai une poitrine extraordinaire
j'ai un simple plus grands kloet moins
cher
c'est mon premier mari avait l'habitude
de s'endormir en le prenant dans sa main
il dormait dans l'autre chambre au bout
du couloir mais évidemment enfin cela
dit mes confrères je trouve que j'aidais
robert hossein mir hossein shirani nab
après une fin d'année 82 mouvementée
vous allez prendre un peu de repos mais
tu sais mon drucker inamori chérie chéri
je vais toujours à pâques à rome
n'est ce pas et gb également aller dans
une vieille propriété de famille nous
l'avons depuis cinq générations
c'est moi qui l'ait fait bâtir au bord
du loch ness la question x1 dise quels
sont vos projets pour 83 mais tu sais
j'ai déjà donné mon corps à la science
elle a refusé alors je j'ai vu
réussir mais faire engager pour une
grande série télévisée - chérie chéri
ce serait la vedette on me verra pas
tout la france défigurée police a pris
série de lyon
bonsoir
jouer à l'autruche en plus mais pour un
plus le gâter bail
fini les strass de vegas et les strass
dégueulasse
vk
toute une vie
t
sans ascenseurs escaliers michel tu te
rends compte nous quelques heures
kim à t'aimer
tout ça c'était la mi mai
jacques chirac
les wc bat rennes
en faisant des petits
changer la vie
je veux dire croyez-moi
mettant chance à la fois
ne venez pas je suis l'amour
sa grâce au lard
bon
ce spectacle
jusqu'au mans
si lui jeta il va
v
pitié
les on est fou de laison
si vous en a
tenez
amman en attendant merci merci ben ouais
ouais voilà j'arrive
bonjour marc demeyer bonjour monsieur
marché mais dites moi qu'est ce que
c'est que ce chien mais je suis passé un
chien un chien des rues où il est
jacques brillet lire regarder son chien
de plus près de lui et j'ai trouvé
devant le faubourg saint honoré devant
l'elysée avec le collier
regardez ça ça doit être le chien
giscard et vanves aussi il a des envies
de revient si ça doit être ça et vous
savoir alors moi je vous écoute europe 1
le matin gentiment à 8h30
si vous êtes ou pré taureau c'est la
grande forme alors richert oui oui et
vous vous levez toum ce marché mais moi
j'ai pas de problème j'ai un réveil
téléphoner c'est youpi 10 ans n'a aucune
autre pas vous y rendre au port louis
qui avons travaillé dans un cagibi et
chasser les taux c'est lé top c'est déjà
visualisé de fer l'intelligence avec
l'ennemi mois que déjà du mal en floride
ruscher et alors j'ai installé ligne
directe chez moi après paris et kremlin
c'est le seul appareil à quels écouteurs
conduit et qu'est-ce que vous prenez le
moteur pouvait jouer à je cite jamais
mon café je mets juste un peu de
sakhaline
il s'est amusé aurait bien comment s'est
passé aux vacances le marché mais très
bien derrière le rideau de fer comme
d'habitude tu vas dire qu'ils louent
pour moi il revêt ce après moi j'ai un
avantage je vais aller en union
soviétique et je peux en sortir chez ni
juive ni intellectuel comme premier set
et même ailleurs alors voilà et puis
tout s'est très bien passé à la fête de
l'huma vous a pas vu des loyers pu venir
y avait de la place surtout au stand des
droits de l'homme y avait personne mais
et parce en a vendu 300 tonnes de
merguez pour la fête des travailleurs
voient voilà l'icwa monsieur oui
monsieur marc chez moi quand je vois la
télévision jouer un peu tendu ben j'ai
d'abord je n'ai pas jamais à la
télévision j'ai souvent l'occasion de
mon plein dans la télévision
et oui comment je vais vous ferez vous
n'êtes plus en plus d'audience faut que
ce soit un repas à la tv on voit que
vous partez
souriau jour bronzé et souriant
weprin s'orienteront rassuré je donnais
un coup remet ce marché xav des cadres
et le sourire oui t'as briouze naturel
non cadré c'est oui voilà bien sûr j'ai
pas que je vais sembla bouchardeau barça
a masqué la dernière fois que j'ai vu à
la tv c'était même la première fois que
je le voyais j'ai écrites pour tous
était déréglé 50 ans wade bouchardon se
dit elle va graver les fils et de la
sécurité sociale cette femme là et elles
gagnent en garde et on tombe malade de
6è ce marché oui vous avez quelque chose
à nous dire
ben oui j'ai quand même un message à
faire passer ce même de vendre nombreux
téléspectateurs est à 2
oui ceux-là mes chers camarades et je
suis heureux et ému d'être là car vous
le savez j'aime adresse aux trente voix
hier et renvoyer un grand pavois yeahs
aux masses populaires
on craint laborieuse lit de l'autre côté
ah oui et pour défendre les intérêts
fondamentaux des grands intérêts de tous
contre la droite à giscard d'estaing qui
était financée par les grands triste
international noces et les grandes
sociétés multinationales aux prêts j'ai
beaucoup lit sachez le oui parce que
drucker encore et il fallut que vous le
souci oui et j'ai beaucoup lit génie les
hev des grands inspirateurs du parti pc
pierre cardin carmax qui a dit le
capitalisme c'est l'exploitation de l'or
parlons mais soyez rassuré plus cher oui
les socialistes exactement conference
board
mais ce marché de pervis je vous ai
amené un petit cadeau oui d'accord oui
c'étaient des ouvriers ça me fait
plaisir que c'est pas une bombe à
retardement vous inquiétez pas non c'est
le stand de venir à la fête de l'huma
effet près visiter s'ils en avaient mis
un boeing de korean air lines a et celui
qui tirait dans le mille gagnant la
carte du parti si vous savez ce que
c'est c'est mon emblème c'est un peu
comme mon cerveau ces noix de coco
devient pour un coco à la noix comme
vous séduire dehors et c'est mou dedans
thierry le luron
ça c'est une surprise j'avais ptld la
halle à la retraite alors oui je on
s'attend au puisqu'ils luxe qui va le
présenter pour seul champ 10 est
extraordinaire il faut bien dire autour
notre gilbert bécaud nationale avec les
choeurs de champs elysées au pavillon
gabriel atteint anti gibert et
sanguinaire il faut bien dire
- petit mail
à 3 ans
fille d'un jour extraordinaire a bien
marqué d'une pierre vivre est marrant
les ai pris pour ce temps un troll
hunter locataires eux un socialiste
exemple et mitterrand
temps c'est la rose l'emmerdant c'est
quoi c'est la rose l'emmerdent chante
rose trois mois
ayé titre j'ai pas répéter
larose nous piquent au sens la france
est au goutte à goutte
s'endettant que que coûte
pour longtemps
ouais à ce rythme évidemment c'est
bientôt la banque eux vous de cap c'est
déjà la démo dans chanteur
non
c'est la rose
c'est quoi
maire d'anchamps et la rose
sa détient
ce soir là champs elysées c'est la
fiesta l'inflation elle
c'est pas la joie de téléphone
et les censeurs en france x
j'ai dit au président
cette chanson ce poème en forme deux
aiguilles et vous
incertain
non
c'est quoi
allons aussi là
avant place à référendum ça continue
l'an
demandez des corps c'est la roue
11 3 mois
là
verdict série merci beaucoup terrine
oui le secteur de niche à haute valeur
voir des choses qui arrivent
merci thierry le 16 novembre sur la
scène du gymnase à samedi j'espère
pourvoir